coughing or cremation rory i'm gonna go
cremation you are i think cemeteries are
so stupid i think you're gonna be so
stupid i thought for sure you're gonna
say scary no you think they're dumb
i don't think they're scary i'm not a
child
i'm not actually a granddaughter pete
i'm a real man
i'm envelopable
you said it yourself i'm afraid of
cemeteries you're afraid of them get out
of there what hours of the day are you
going to cemetery if you're going at
night i can understand being concerned
yes oh so you're not only because you're
not supposed to be there not because a
zombie's gonna get you
only because security's gonna be like
what's your deal pal
that's true
but i'm just in a cemetery i didn't know
you were closed
well you think you think they're dumb
you know that's a good argument because
those hours aren't posted anywhere
you're not seeing that
you're not seeing that as you pull into
a cemetery oh it says they're closed
come on diane let's get out of here
why is why is diane also that brave shut
up come on
nighttime visitation yeah yeah you're
not thinking about hours you're grieving
yeah but uh it's i think they're stupid
it takes up so much space why do you
need to be
in the ground nothing well in amsterdam
they dig them up and uh you only get a
time in it good
good for them
finally someone's doing it right
yes you can be buried for six months
and then we throw you in the ocean
oh the ocean
that's a couple reading the brochure oh
then they throw us in the ocean
they're into it
it's the most base-priced package
but they're trying to put a positive
spin on it
then we throw you in the ocean near
dolphins honey we're gonna be near
dolphins
oh
they shoot us out of a cannon
this is gonna be the that
why do we we don't need we don't need
cemeteries and that's why i'm here
tonight
that's why i'm here
we don't need cemeteries
how have i been living without it
i'm not done with it i'm not either an
old couple yeah
but also what are you asking or
wondering what he's doing while she's
reading the ropes
i am too like why is he why won't he
participate
why isn't he like what is that saying
they heave us into the goddamn ocean
he's pulling out another brochure well
this one gives us eight months in the
ground for half the price and they throw
us in front of a locomotive
that's not as fun as the ocean i went to
the museum of death where they put on
display this is in amsterdam all the
eyeglasses and the wallets and pocket
watches of the people they dig up so not
only are you dug up but then you're part
of an exhibit
it's nuts it's real i was there and i
don't know if you believe in ghosts but
while we were there a lot of doors were
slamming real
you said wallets
yeah people are going into the
ground with the wallet
still in the pocket
no one searched no one gave a quick pat
right before they closed it
well really none of it makes sense why
do you need a pocket watch why they
still did
yeah i heard about a guy who put a phone
in his uh in his coffin just in case he
woke up
imagine getting the voicemail
hey it's bill yeah the guy you laughed
at about the whole dead phone
call me i'm not going anywhere
i'm here i'm still down here
got a few i know i can go 172 hours
i know i can go that long down here it's
james frank i thought that was funnier
i thought that was funny you got to keep
them on us yeah